E
WHO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THIS IS
HAPPENING ARE DOING VERY WELL.
ADAM LAXALT IS ONE OF THEM,
RUNNING FOR THE SENATE AND HE
JOINS US TONIGHT.
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
IS YOUR OPPONENT EVEN WILLING TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THE COUNTRY IS
BEING OVERTURNED BY A SURGE IN
VIOLENT CRIME?
>> DEFINITELY NOT A TOPIC SHE
WANTS TO FOCUS ON.
IN FACT SHE'S CLOSING THE RACE
WITH JOHN LEGEND, UNKNOWN DEFUND
THE POLICE ADVOCATE.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS SHE'S RUNNING
AWAY FROM HER RECORD EVERY
SECOND OF THE RACE.
IT'S WHY WE PULLED AHEAD.
IT'S A TIGHT RACE.
THEY'RE SPENDING ALMOST
$90 MILLION TO DEFEAT ME BUT
THIS IS THE 51ST SEAT AND THE
DEMOCRATS WANT TO TRY TO SAVE
HER.
WE'VE HAD LAS VEGAS POLICE
FLIPPED TO ME.
THEY'RE FED UP.
THEY WANT SOMEONE TO STAND WITH
THE POLICE THROUGH AND THIN,
LIKE YOU DID THROUGH THE BLM
RIOTS.
SHE HAS SAID SHE SUPPORTS BLM
AND THAT COPS ARE SYSTEMICALLY
RACIST.
NOW SHE TRIES TO PRETEND SHE
SUPPORTS THE POLICE BUT THE COPS
AREN'T BUYING IT FOR ONE SECOND.
THEY KNOW ONLY ONE CANDIDATE
STANDS FOR POLICE.
THEY KNOW IT'S EXISTENTIAL FOR
THEM.
WE HAVE TO GET OUR COMMUNITIES
CLEANED UP.
THIS IS WHY THE RACES SWING IN
OUR DIRECTION.
YES ITS ECONOMY ABOUT LAW AND
ORDER ON BORDER ISSUES ARE A
HUGE PIECE OF WHITE PEOPLE ARE
FED UP AND WANT SOMETHING
DIFFERENT.
>> Tucker: SOME CREEPY
HOLLYWOOD DEFUND THE POLICE
IMAGES.
DOES ANYONE NOTICE THIS?
>> NOBODY'S COVERING IT.
WE PUT OUT A PRESS RELEASE BUT
THE MEDIA IGNORE IT.
THEY WON'T COVER THAT BIDEN CAME
OUT WEST, SKIP NEVADA, AND HE'S
AT 37%.
HE WANTED TO BE A MONTH AGO AND
SAID, WHAT YOU MEAN, DEFUND THE
POLICE?
WE SUPPORT THE POLICE.
BUT SHE WANTS NOTHING TO DO WITH
HIM EVEN THOUGH SHE HAS
SUPPORTED THEM EVERY STEP OF THE
WAY.
>> Tucker: THERE'S NO WAY YOU
COULD WIN IN NEVADA, THEY SAID.
BUT YOU